elle aura attendu près de dix ans et
différentes expériences au sein
d'ateliers pour enfin se lancer
sarah toc aven a publié cet été son
premier ouvrage le bruit du bonheur une
aventure débutée il ya deux ans pour la
versaillaise
à un moment j'ai eu envie de me
consacrer à quelque chose de plus
personnel parce que les ateliers on
travaille ensemble il ya une véritable
émulation mais finalement on ne
travaille pas sur sur un seul projet
puisque les thèmes c'est le coach
qui est qui les organisent et donc ils
sont différents à chaque fois et sont
inhérents à l'animateur lui-même inspiré
du vécu de l'auteur le bruit du bonheur
n'est pas un roman autobiographique pour
autant il raconte l'histoire d'alexandre
un père de famille déboussolée par la
mort de sa mère et le divorce avec sa
femme sa vie va alors prendre un nouveau
départ lors de l'été familiale suivant
et des vacances avec sa fille
adolescente
il va se retrouver à l'occasion des
vacances d'été pour la première fois un
peu en tête à tête avec sa fille qui
elle est adolescente et voilà et là
c'est un peu la relation père fille
qu'il va découvrir à l'occasion de ces
vacances
et dans leur maison familiale il va
découvrir leurs secrets de famille un
secret familial à succès plus de 500
exemplaires du bruit du bonheur ont été
vendus depuis le mois de juin l'ouvragé
autoédité est disponible seulement via
internet